[Music]
[Applause]
sao paolo antonio espn national
correspondent covering the nfl primarily
his 30th training camp
in canton hall last week dick vermeel
even even gave him a shout out in his
hall of fame speech he's been to the
eagles camp heading to the colts
commanders giants and jets camps also a
voter for the pro football hall of fame
and sao paulo antonio joining us on the
program sal great to talk to you again
i'm curious
do you want to be the first reporter who
tries ayahuasca
if you're a great reporter just to be
able to relate to aaron rodgers would
you be willing to try ayahuasca
you got me on that one dad
right out of the gate brother i love it
and you know if you don't do it andrea
kramer is going to do it
well that
you know and then she'll get on with
brian gumpel
we'll get out that pad and make some
notes and ask her some coaching
questions and we'll all be very
entertained
whenever i watch real sports with brian
gumbel i always want to know what he's
writing down because
you know we used to do that when we'd be
on sportscenter we would fake we would
mock the people who would be writing
down stuff you know after a newscast
like the newscast would be over and
you'd see the anchor write down
something and we'd do that at the end of
sportscenter because
there was nothing you could write down
after the show is over but brian always
writes these notes down when he's he's
hosting real sports and by the way uh my
money's on the fearless andrea kramer
with ayahuasca yes yeah
that makes sense all right um we just
we're talking about the i have a bat i
think the lions are going to be over six
wins this year they're uh
they're hard knocks this year do you
want to uh jump in on that
uh i say no i don't think the lions will
be over six wins i i think uh it is wide
open in the nfc i think they'll be much
more competitive yeah
but i think teams are just going to
blitz their quarterback
and they won't have much answer on
offense and i think it will start week
one when the eagles go into detroit i
think uh
right now it's a blitzing league dan
and if your quarterback can't get out of
the way of the blitz jimmy garoppolo
good example yeah uh you know you're
looking for a dual threat quarterback
you're looking for somebody who can get
out of the way of the blitz and the
reason why
it's become a blitzing league is because
you know two years ago that point of
emphasis of
let's not call ticky tack offensive
holding so the offensive holding calls
went way down in 2020 points scored went
way up and defensive coordinators were
like hey
if you're not going to call offensive
holding we got to get to the quarterback
somehow
so we got a blitz
the worst team in football this year
will be
oh
i i think it could be still the new york
jets it'll be between new york and
jacksonville in terms of record i would
say those are the two that will struggle
the most
i think jacksonville will get better
eventually
two or three years into doug peterson's
reign
i think trevor lawrence i spoke with him
after the hall of fame game on the field
he's in a better place than he was
last year with urban meyer clearly
and doug knows what he's doing he turned
around the eagles after the chip kelly
disaster
uh but it'll be a little bit of a
struggle for them they got a really
tough schedule so do the jets look at
the jets schedule dan
brutal absolutely brutal
i was wondering about the bears feels
like they have justin fields and nothing
else
roquan smith wants out
uh the texans
i don't know what the texans really have
that they would be in the running for
the uh the worst team in the nfl
anybody candidates yeah
you don't want to be a candidate on that
list but
it certainly feels that way uh you're on
the hall of fame committee i wanted to
ask you i vote on the heisman but nobody
tells you what to factor in
voting on the heisman you know there's
no you got to consider this when you
vote on hall of fame
are you given any parameters of
what you must include or not include
no but there's quite a bit of
information gathering
by all of the voters and you know once
you get into the room
uh on the day before the super bowl
you know there's a presentation made
there's some really good ones bob
globber makes some great presentations
ira kaufman makes some great
presentations uh over there's peter king
uh vic carrucci they you know the
presentations are detailed they're
passionate you go in there
really you know
pounding the table for your guy
and you're trying to get him in you know
i was
you know honored to be the the
representatives for paul tagliabue and
harold carmichael and dick vermeel
recently but it takes a team dan so in
vermeel's case you know carl peterson
and
ron jaworski and the eagles pr
department and paul damowitz of the
philadelphia daily news they all get
stuff they get letters they'll call
voters
there's a lobbying campaign it's not
you know they say it's supposed to be
organic well it's organic for peyton
manning and brett favre and ray lewis
but for everybody else you got to get
votes
but how when's the last time you it got
really heated the most heated that
you've been involved with
well
i would say
the paul tagliabue debate was
challenging and difficult you know he
was the first one that came out of the
contributors committee that was rejected
by the committee in the whole
first and only
so that that debate was difficult and uh
there were a lot there were a lot of
really good
uh challenging discussions i wouldn't
say it was heated at all i would say
they were very challenging discussions
in the room these are professionals who
have been doing it for a long time and
they gather their information and
they're passionate uh and uh you know
what they do is highly professional for
the hall of fame and i i'm just proud to
be part of it and then of course we had
the centennial committee that i was on
with bill belichick and ron wolf
the late great our great friend john
clayton
and uh tagliboo got in through the
centennial committee uh for the 100th
anniversary of the league
i was also wondering about this
i go back to gayle sayers who had a
shortened career when he blew out his
knee
and then i didn't feel like we had
anybody who had that shortened career
but got in because they were
unbelievable for five years then terrell
davis got in and i wonder what role
terrell davis getting in helped tony
beselli get in and can that help
sterling sharp get in at the wide
receiver position
there's no question td getting in help
tony beselly now tony pasel he was on
the old deck a team of the 90s even
though he only played five years that's
truly exceptional all those pro bowls
turning the franchise around
you know my partner on the match-up show
greg cosell i used his quote in in the
meeting
uh where greg coselli said he was the
best tackle he ever saw on film i mean
the guy was truly great
and you know greatness can be defined at
certain time frames obviously he was
voted on the old decade team needed to
get in but td getting in helped him
sterling sharp's in a different category
because he's in the seniors so this year
for the first time the seniors are
nominating three candidates to get in
and i've got shirlene sharp
as the number one senior candidate i'm
not voting on the senior committee but
i'm voting in the committee in the whole
i think randy gratishaw everson walls
and and what about ken anderson i mean
you look at ken anderson's career with
the bengals
it matches up really well with some guys
who got in the hall of fame like dan
fout so i think ken anderson to me is
one of the most underrated players of
all time and and should get serious
consideration by the senior committee
i'm sure he will
yeah i've been kind of banging that drum
having grown up in cincinnati and
watched him play uh kenny reilly to me
is another defensive back who i think
should be in the hall of fame
um
but you know factoring in kenny anderson
getting in you know if he beat montana
in the super bowl
he might be in the hall of fame like i
don't you know it's like if eli had one
super bowl and not two so is he a hall
of fame quarterback
probably not but eli manning i will vote
for him okay first ballot to get in two
super bowls
two super bowl mvps there are five guys
that got two super bowl mvps three of
them are already in the hall the other
guys brady
and eli manning so to me eli goes in
how do you factor in philip rivers
career when
you know that the totality of it
and lack of postseason success i think
he'll definitely get serious
consideration dan there's no question in
my mind that he'll make the final 15
he'll be quote unquote what we like to
say in the room yeah on the day before
the super bowl and there'll be a very
passionate argument for phil rivers
without a doubt
the running back position frank gore
hall of fame hall of fame hall of fame
ricky waters
roger correct i've been saying that
ricky waters felt like he was marshall
faulk before marshall falk and you can
say roger craig might have
been in that category that hybrid
running back wide you know uh pass
catcher
i i'm a big believer in roger kirk
getting in and i think ricky waters
should be getting consideration and he
probably will i think both of them
eventually will get some serious
consideration
uh i don't know why roger craig has not
gotten traction
uh but you look at his numbers and the
way i think he redefined the running
back position clearly in the bill walsh
offense
paulie has been banging the drum for
tiki barber
and
i i he has numbers
but then they win the super bowl the
year after he retires
are you a tiki barber hall of famer
fanboy
i i
i gotta look at it dan i think i think
he he's in the conversation but if you
have to look cell then maybe he's not a
hall of famer yeah well i'm not as smart
as you dan so i'm gonna look i'm gonna
[ __ ] i'm gonna check it out all right
paulie you wanna you wanna tell sound
yep paulie you wanna help sound yeah
i'll tell a little bit about football
here
now i'm not even a tiki barber fan
personally and i'm not a giants fan my
theory is he started out as a good third
down running back for his first four
years and we kind of pegged him as that
but his last five seasons he had four
seasons with 2 000 or more all-purpose
yards the only other guys in that
category are dickerson falk and walter
payton he had uh five seasons over 1200
yards he also had 600 catches
and he did most of it in a six season
span
why don't you put the a dossier together
an email
and i'll present it to the committee i'm
i'm an open mind
paulie will do it
paulie will do it do it yeah todd's got
my email send it over
uh joe thomas hall of famer darrell
rivas hall of famer you see that
happening i think i think joe thomas
yeah he's he's up for 2023. i i could
see him first ballot
getting in right away yeah but revis i
could see him getting it right away but
do the football voters
have that bias like the baseball writers
do with the first ballot like ah you
can't make first ballot it's cal ripken
you know like do you do you find that
it's really hard
to get in first ballot with the football
writers
no i don't think that it is okay i think
there's some people who would like to
reserve first ballot for truly special
players like
again ray lewis peyton manning
brett favre
tom brady those those are first ballot
and uh i'm i mean i'm sort of in that
category dan i'm sort of in that
category joe thomas's first ballot to me
i think zach thomas is a hall of famer
but and he's he doesn't get mentioned
and i i remember talking to peyton
manning and he said he might be the
brightest guy i ever faced because it
felt like he knew what
we were doing like
he felt like he he was ahead of you
and you were you know the quarterback on
the uh you know against him so i i don't
know if he gets any traction whatsoever
or what would be the hold i who do we
talk to yesterday oh ross tucker said he
thought that zach thomas was better than
brian erlocker even though he thinks
brian erlocker's a hall of famer
but why is zach thomas not get love
he gets a lot of love dan he's been in
the final 15 for a number of years so um
i think he's close actually i think he's
real close and i think he's very
deserving super tough super smart very
productive
uh definitely a hall of famer it's just
a matter of when
uh the nfc east do you have the eagles
winning or the cowboys i have the eagles
winning
there's pretty shocking
uh but i do i think uh having seen them
have been around them i think they're
going to be much more competitive
in areas where they were deficient last
year
the passing game their pass rush
their past defense and coverage and on
the back end will all be better and at
the linebacker position their schedule
is very favorable
which i think is important i always look
at schedule and how many pro bowl
quarterbacks are you playing on the road
no that to me is very important when you
look at the over under how many pro bowl
quality or pro bowl quarterbacks are you
playing
on the road and the eagles don't play
very many on the road so i think
that puts them in rarefied air in terms
of the s easy part of their schedule so
i like them a lot and i think having
seen jalen hurts in the last two years
just think about this
in the same offense with the same
offensive coaches for two years in a row
for the first time since he was 16 years
old
uh he goes to california
he gets three or four weeks of really
good training on his footwork and
mechanics it's really showed his core of
his body is stronger
his base is more solid
he's delivering the ball definitely with
much more
velocity
and accuracy now he just has to make
quick decisions you know the big thing
the big misconception out there right
now is progressions with young
quarterbacks
dan they're cutting the field in half
and there really is it's read
throw or go
read throw or go right now for young
quarterbacks you cut you look at the
safety and then you cut the field in
half and you're making you should have
in your past concept one or two throws
if you don't have them then you're gone
that's why trey lance will be much
better than jimmy garoppolo i think
uh who do you think has a better year
jalen hurts or uh tuatanga by law
i think it'll be jayla hurts okay
yeah i think two is going to be good i
think you know listen there's so many
quarterbacks that are in a
proven year like three of the four
quarterbacks in the nfc east prove it
years
uh
brand new quarterbacks in in the afc
south i i call this the year of living
dangerously in the nfl because there's
so many unknowns
you just start with a 45 year old
quarterback as the
you know one of the top super bowl
contenders in the nfc has a 45 year old
quarterback
great unknown and by the way dan can you
remember the last time
that the two quarterbacks in the super
bowl or the rams and the bengals
started out not really practicing
in training camp the following year
great unknown for the bengals what what
are we going to get joe burrow back on
the field and see what he can do post
appendectomy
great unknown for the rams with the
tendonitis with matthew stafford
great unknown with jalen hurts with tua
it's all over the league russell wilson
changing teams i mean there's a lot of
uncertainty at the most important
position in the league and i think that
the league has never been more wide open
than i've seen it for 30 years i've been
around will you get your appendectomy
your appendix out
just to understand what joe burrows
going through
you will not okay all right andrea
kramer you said andrea kramer already
did yeah yesterday wow
that's the difference cell
what is the difference that's why she's
in the hall of fame yes she is a hall of
famer yeah
all right
you are tiki barber sal
all right that's good
thank you
hey dan i want to be you someday
uh good to talk to you buddy
yes sir that's sal palantonio